hello everyone and welcome to the best
game uh of the
first day of the us championship well
what i think is the best game
i've seen uh all of the decisive ones
and this is the one i enjoyed most so
it's the one i decided to show
and it's a game from round one uh two of
the america's finest young gentleman
jeffrey shiong and the wanderling
uh i think is about 19 years old whereas
uh liang is 17
so very very young but extremely strong
uh
grandmasters and uh well there's a lot
on the line
will some of them surprise and uh will
win this event or will hikaru nakamura
uh you know win it for the sixth or
seventh time uh
i believe it's the i believe he has six
titles and this could be his seventh
but but we'll see what happens however
uh it's not a classical event it's a
rapid event uh 25 minutes for the entire
game plus a five
second increment starting from move one
uh as it says so under under website
and uh regarding uh a tie a tie for
first place will be determined by
two ten plus two rapid games and if
still tied
in armageddon game will be played where
white has five minutes to blacks four
but a draw counts as a win for black of
course and
uh there's 150 000 dollars to be won uh
all together with
forty thousand dollars being uh the
prize for first place so
a lot to play for and uh like i said
this is the one game i enjoyed most so
let's
let's check it out uh so xium with the
white pieces opens with knight to f3
uh starts with uh uh already opening we
have knight to f6 and now
d4 uh we have sorry about that
uh we have g6 uh going for some sort of
a
an indian setup and the knight beat the
d2 we have d5
and b4 now looks weird but it has been
played before many times with bishop to
g7 as a white so
conveniently opened up this diagonal and
now e3 strengthening the center we have
castles by black
and bishop to e2 so white also continues
development prepares the castle
and c6 strengthening the center uh we
have castles by white
and now uh a5 striking here attacking
the the b4 pawn
this setup is very nice as it prevents
black from immediately going c
c 5 but black wants to undermine the b
for pawn
uh maybe get him to capture open up his
uh a file for the rook
and then at some point uh get this c5
moving so white uh advances it the b5
and now
says okay well you can capture it i'm
defending it with the bishop you're
gonna mess up your pawn structure so
instead we have c5
and with this uh the battle for the for
the center continues and here there is
one game in the database
database uh eva moser versus vladimir uh
buckland from 2018 bundesliga where
bishop to b2
was played and black was able to win
this game here we have c3 and
uh it is as of move nine that we have a
completely new game
uh so let's see let's see what happens
here uh knight b to d7
uh black continues development now we'll
have some pressure in the center maybe
e5
is an idea for for the future uh we have
a4
strengthening the pawn here and now b6
black does the same and also black will
want to develop his light square bishop
on this diagonal that's a weird arrow i
know but the the new interface allow you
know allows you to do that
uh so here bishop to a3 white does the
same he wants his bishop on
a nice diagonal and now bishop to b7
we have c4 here white has to decide what
to do whether to first start with rook
to c1
rook to e1 and then try and go for the
breakthrough or to go for the
breakthrough right away because this is
one point you don't want uh
to remain behind so c4 putting more
pressure on the center and
rook the c8 black gets the rook to the
to the one file that might open up soon
and white does the same we have rook to
c1 and now
rook to e8 uh and here uh white
continues with c
captures on d5 with knight characters on
the e5 and now
d captures on c5 uh and here uh it's a
very important capture because uh
regardless of how black recaptures first
uh with the knight and then whether to
go with the pawn
or with the rook you will leave black
with a
with a very weak a5 pawn so that's
that's a problem for black so knight
captures on c5 was played
of course white happily captures with
the bishop we have b captures on c5 or
you could capture with the rook but the
the
the end result is the same after pawn
captures the a5 pawn will
still be weak so here we have b
characters in c5 and
queen to b3 now so now black has a weak
a5 pawn
uh and uh well white has a pass b pawn
whereas black has a past c
pawn so a bit of a trade off however uh
white's b5 pawn is defended whereas the
black c5 point is not and
again there there's the problem of the
a5 pawn and it's not going to be easy to
defend it so
knight back to b6 uh preparing uh to
push the pawn at some point also
attacking the a4 pawn and rook f2d1 now
threatening some nasty discoveries as
the queen is still on d8
uh we have queen to c7 and now knight to
c4
putting pressure on this knight
preparing to bring the other knight into
the game
and also putting immediate pressure on
a5 so here
bishop to d5 pinning the knight but
white replies with knight after d2 he
says okay my knight is nicely defended
next i'm going to move the queen
and the threat remains so here we have
rook e to d8 and now comes queen to c2
so now white is ready to capture the
pawn
while keeping an eye on the a4 pawn here
and
here you could do a lot of things you
could start by capturing on c4 for
example knight captures captures and
another captures for example a nice rook
trade with
uh with check sorry first bishop
captures
and then we we could do a trade or
instead you could go for rook after 78
first
queen captures and then bishop captures
on c4 so this is one option for black
where
uh white still gets his uh uh protected
pass pawn and
black still uh has his pass pawn but
still keeps uh the the weak a5
pawn so this is one way to for black to
play this however
uh xiong decides to go uh for a
different line he decides
not to eliminate the the knight here
twice
but rather he goes for e6 and now this
is a bit of a problem for him
because although he's not going to lose
any material
he will run into some problems because
here
knight captures on a5 was of course
played and now
rook to a8 uh attacking the knight but
also if the knight moves then the a4
pawn is under attack so here we have
knight to d to c4
uh defending the knight on a5 but just
knight
captures on c4 uh is possible however
bishop captures on c4 was played
uh we have knight captures on c4 and now
of course
knight captures on a4 so it's uh the
material is the same
nothing really changed here however it
is it is a bit different
why it seems like white has something
more here than he did in the previous
line
so here bishop to f3 and this is an
incredibly strong move
you grab hold of this diagonal you no
longer allow the rook to remain there
and the rook will have uh the rook will
have a lot of problems here because the
rook has to keep an eye on the knight
here
and the only square uh well available
for you is
uh after this trade with czech
characters captures is rook to a7
and now there's a problem here how do
you continue this game for white it's uh
still not uh like uh like a completely
crushing move but
there is a really beautiful move that
really puts a lot of pressure here
on black's position so feel free to
pause the video and continue this game
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
incredibly powerful rook to d6 uh so
also for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show now the problem is
uh the b6 square is now defended twice
and the b6
is a real problem for uh for black and
there i mean it's not easy to counter it
for example if you try something like
queen to b8 let's just try and make a
move you keep an
eye on the on the d8 square it's uh it's
really
bad actually because after b6 yes you
can now move the rook
but now comes queen to d3 and now you're
threatening to win the queen
also if the knight moves that rook looks
very very awkward on a6
so one way blackett continues like
bishop to f8 you still go for rook to d8
and
now uh there's uh there's nowhere for
the queen to go because this is covered
by the bishop this is protected
the pawn doesn't allow access to the a7
and c7 squares and of course
every square on this dark square
diagonal is taken so here black
seems to be losing the queen however
there is this
knight to b2 idea we're just going to
show it because it's really beautiful
and it seems like you can just grab the
knight for free however this is even
stronger you just trade
queens captures captures and now king to
f1 you don't want to allow any back rank
mating ideas so here black is just
completely lost uh the the pass pawn is
too strong
even if you try and stop it let's say
rook a4 b7 and rook to b4 just rook to
d8 and now there's the problem still
defended
uh threatening the queen threatening to
capture the knight there's just no
no move here for black so that's a one
one way to play it uh if you play with
queen to b8 uh
in the in the actual game uh the move
that was played is
knight to c3 so you kind of have to uh
prepare for something
and knight the c3 was played here making
room for this rook to deliver this check
however the absolute strongest here was
knight to b2 and
we are going to show it just because
it's uh super super complicated and so
you would
uh more easily understand why it's
stronger than knight to c3 it's
basically a tempo stronger and that's
what makes all the difference so point
being after this knight to b2 idea white
still continues with b6 but now there's
rook to a1 check rook to d1 blocking
uh the problem with blocking with the
bishop is that queen captures and d6 is
just too strong
after you capture the queen just knight
captures on d1 and
there's no defense here black threatens
all sorts of mating discoveries
uh and there's simply no way to defend
against that if you try something like
h3
okay you will save against mate but just
a a discovered
check picks up the queen and the rook is
more than
more than fast enough to stop the past
pawn uh
so one thing you could try is let's say
b7 but still just knight captures on e3
with
check you have to give up the queen
captures and this is made
so returning to our idea of knight to b2
uh
with the idea of b6 and rook to a1 check
you cannot block with the bishop you
have to block with the rook
but now comes rook captures with check
and now
queen captures this is the point
uh so uh here queen to b8 of course you
don't uh want to
do anything stupid uh because if the
queen is captured then just pawn
captures there's uh
well the problem of not being able to
stop the pawn so queen to b8 and now
knight uh characters and b2 grabbing
that knight here
bishop captures on b2 and now let's say
b7
you have a protected pass pawn on b7 and
uh
well it's going to be a problem for
black however it queens on a dark square
black only one with the dark square
bishop the light square bishop will not
be able to support
the the queening of the pawn so it's
very hard to say if white could actually
play this out for a win i i don't think
i i don't think so as black also has a
pass pawn that's very strong
so it would be i i think it would be a
draw uh so that's
what would happen here if knight the bt
was played however in the actual game
knight to c3 was played
and this is uh well only a little bit
different but it is different because
the game continues in the absolute same
way
b6 attacking the rook and the queen here
rook to a1
with check and now rook to d1 blocking
now the problem is of course that uh the
queen uh will be captured because here
we have knight captures and d1 with
check and now b captures on c7 so white
is
white is that that little bit closer to
this uh c8 uh
check move and this is a huge problem
uh for black because here knight
captures an e3 check was played
and it seems to be deadly but now bishop
to d1 and here the problem with
capturing with the rook as it does
deliver check
white just gives up the queen white
doesn't care because white pawn is
already on c7 and this
is just completely winning for white so
what actually happened here with knight
captures on c2
black is now threatening checkmate
however white
queens with tempo so a c8 queen with
bishop to f8 blocking still made being
threatened but queen to d8 now the
bishop is guarded and there is no way
for black to add more pressure you can't
go knight e3 you can't go
below the board to attack the bishop so
nothing much for you to do
so here king to g7 was played and now h4
it's still not uh
like still not absolutely
straightforward because it's a rapid
game
you know both players are very low on
time anything could happen if it was a
classical game of course we would see
resigns here uh
an instant resign from black however in
a rapid game you know you
as long as you have a knight you can
still play so knight to d4
and now knight to e3 black goes knight
to f5
offers a trade of knights but now h5
sorry h5 by white
uh we have a trade here on e3 captures
captures and
rook to a6 you cannot capture the bishop
from here but maybe you can play rook d6
attack the queen and then pick up the
bishop
so here bishop back to b3 and now rook
to d6
attacking the queen queen to g5 and now
rook to d7
so black tries to keep everything intact
uh maybe you can
create some sort of a fortress here
white spawns are all messed up
or white has a light square bishop so
maybe you could set up some sort of a
barrier here
but it's still a long way to go queen e5
check king the g8 and now
bishop to c4 just waiting move waiting
to see what black will do
uh rook the d1 with check king to f2 and
now rook to c1 attacks the bishop and
now queen f4
just uh the defense against uh rook
characters and c4
king to g7 and now g4 just improving the
position a little bit bishop to e7
and here queen to e5 with check king to
g8 and now queen to b8 with
check and here bishop to f8 is a must if
black even wants to try and play this
game out
however king the g7 was played and now
of course it's all over i'm sure you can
uh
see what happens even without pausing
the video
uh the rook is on c1 and it's very very
simple
queen to b2 check was played this
connects with the king and the rook
and of course it was in this position on
47
that i wonder liam resigned the game and
a wonderful uh victory for
for jeffrey young in round one of the us
championship
uh so yeah uh that's uh i think this was
the nicest game played
in the first day of the us championship
so i do think uh i do hope you guys
enjoyed it
uh and yeah uh that's that's the game i
really hope you enjoyed it because it
was
really crazy i would like to thank david
kimura
wallace don woody uh oluwatoshi sunny
kirby wilson and john then for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
uh i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the us
championship if so
if a nice game such as this one arises
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day